I would tell you if I'm a photographer
right now the number one place I would
build an audience on number one can I
guess know you'd take it I think I kind
of preview it oh you did actually that's
why I don't want you don't worry credit
won't this month the audience the number
one place I think that they should be
building an audience on is snapchat let
me explain why
so snapchat for people that are watching
the talk is about naked selfies right
and all this jargon
the reality is boom the reality is is
that snapchat is the one place that you
can almost guarantee consumption because
the picture disappears people actually
click it and look at it for those eight
seconds whereas in Twitter and Facebook
you don't see everything you're just
going through too quickly weird snapchat
you actually give that photo oh by the
way you give it those 7 10 11 seconds
I've been able to drive much bigger
business results trending topics on
Twitter through snapchat over the last
two months than I've been able to do
through any other platform if I'm a
photographer the ability for me to take
a photo and then send it to my snapchat
audience and actually have it consumed
and right on top of it unless you're a
purist I get it you know but the truth
is that to me is a place where they need
to be paying attention to and so it goes
on and on and on